installez-vous en direct bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité ce matin
secrétaire général de Force Ouvrière on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
Julien ducuyer de la Voix du Nord
bonjour Julien bonjour monsieur
on a donc été nommé première ministre
vous allez avoir un entretien avec elle
demain je crois qu'elle est le message
que vous allez lui faire passer le
message d'abord je la féliciterai quand
même pour sa nomination
mais surtout elle était ministre du
Travail sous l'autorité d'un Premier
ministre elle est maintenant chef du
gouvernement
le président de la République a invoqué
ou évoqué un changement de méthode et ce
que je vais lui expliquer d'abord c'est
que le changement de méthode pour nous
ça doit consister certes à nous écouter
mais à tenir compte du fait que nous
avons des arguments sur les différents
aspects sur lesquels on a l'intention de
faire valoir les urgences il y a pouvoir
d'achat salaire et il y a le sujet des
retraites
on va juste revenir sur ces sujets mais
petite question sur cet entretien c'est
un entretien en bilatérale ou est-ce que
les autres partenaires sociaux seront
reçus en même temps que vous non demain
c'est un premier échange ambilatéral ça
va être très court c'est un tour de
d'horizon général et sans doute sur le
comportement et peut-être on verra si
elle a déjà en tête un agenda mais on
sait aussi qu'on est dans la période
législative au gouvernement est-ce que
vous pensez que ce sera avant ou après
la composition du gouvernement ça je ne
peux pas vous dire je ne suis pas dans
les arcanes dans le secret des des dieux
Élisabeth borne c'est quand même aussi
la ministre de la réforme de la SNCF de
l'assurance chômage est-ce que c'est
pour vous une forme de provocation
vis-à-vis des syndicats
non je veux pas dire que c'est
provocation pas provocation qui que ce
serait qui sera Premier ministre et quel
sera le gouvernement au terme des
élections législatives encore une fois
il faut qu'on attende aussi ce que sera
la majorité ou non et dans ce cas-là ce
qui sera important parce que je vais pas
dire quelque chose de très novateur par
rapport à tout ce qui se dit en ce
moment mais il y a une vraie question
aujourd'hui dans le cadre des
institutions la Cinquième République et
du quinquennat sur
l'autorité du chef du gouvernement
vis-à-vis du président de la République
moi je suis frappé par le fait que les
candidats à la présence de la République
dont celui qui a été élu porte un
programme économique et social très
détaillé ce qui n'était pas le cas dans
le passé du septennat de ce qu'on
concevait être le rôle d'un président de
la République donc là le problème qu'on
a c'est que est-ce que le premier
ministre est un exécutant des volontés
du président de la République
une marge de manœuvre pas de marche de
manœuvre non je ne sais pas je ne peux
pas vous le dire je pense que avec
Monsieur Castex on a fait le constat qui
avait une autorité qui s'était affirmée
de sa part alors il était arrivé en
juillet 2020 avec justement je pense
cette volonté d'affichage d'un d'une
relation qui tiennent un peu plus compte
de l'importance de la relation avec les
interlocuteurs sociaux et on l'a vu si
on prend par exemple la réforme de
l'assurance chômage c'est le premier
ministre à l'époque dont nous avons
obtenu qu'il reporte intégralement la
réforme qui avait été initié du travail
Elisabeth borne
à ce moment-là mais c'est le chef du
gouvernement qui d'après la décision de
la politique d'ensemble du gouvernement
et ces ministres y contribuent bien
évidemment mais celui qui a l'autorité
en premier ou en dernière sorte c'est
normalement le est-ce que ça
la nomination des d'Élisabeth borne
compte tenu des relations que vous avez
pu avoir notamment dans les négociations
on en parlait de l'assurance chômage moi
je ne suis inquiet de rien
l'enjeu pour moi non mais encore une
fois je ne me remets pas dans les mains
de quelques premiers ministres ou
Premier ministre que ce soit l'enjeu
pour moi est d'être capable de me faire
entendre je l'ai dit c'est une
personnalité
compétente qualifiée polytechnicienne
ingénieur déposées chaussées dur en
affaires je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises il faudra que nous soyons
nous-mêmes à la hauteur à la fois dans
les raisons qui font que nous portons
tel ou telle position si je prends la
question du pouvoir d'achat je mettrai
en avant la nécessité de l'augmentation
des salaires y compris du SMIC et si on
parle des retraites je dirais que nous
sommes absolument opposés à toute forme
de de l'âge de départ à la retraite il
nous faudra être convaincant et si on ne
l'est pas suffisamment dans l'échange et
bien il faudra qu'on soit à la hauteur
et qu'on fasse la démonstration que ça
n'est pas simplement tel ou tel
secrétaire général qui parle de tel ou
tel syndicat en l'occurrence pour faux
mais que c'est bien quelque chose qui
est soutenu largement par les salariés
je l'ai dit si on n'est pas entendu nous
nous poserons la question la
mobilisation c'est clair mais dans un
premier temps on va voir si on arrive à
faire vous allez vraiment pas la bonne
idée du moment mais justement sur cette
réforme des retraites est-ce que vous
êtes prêt vous à la discuter et est-ce
que du coup vous êtes prêt à faire des
compromis ah non il y a pas de compromis
possible sur un nouveau recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite 1 nous avons
expliqué en long un large et en travers
que ce qui se pose prioritairement qui
est en question y compris du point de
vue de l'accès à une retraite correcte
et à un dans les conditions de
l'équilibre des systèmes de retraite
c'est l'emploi pour faire en sorte que
tout un chacun est la possibilité d'un
emploi de qualité un emploi pérenne à
temps plein de l'entrée dans la vie
active jusqu'au moment du départ à la
retraite et que l'on fasse en sorte de
sortir tous ceux et toutes celles
surtout qui sont confinés à des emplois
à basse salaire à temps partiel souvent
l'emploi précaire de cette situation si
on commence par résoudre ce problème là
on verra qu'on aura résolu le problème
de l'équilibre des systèmes de retraite
et parallèlement que l'on aura fait en
sorte que tout un chacun accède à une
retraite correcte
et vous parlez de pleine emploi en fait
ce prix emploi il se fabrique pas comme
ça de façon de façon magique
de relocalisation de réindustrialisation
ça a été soulevé pendant la période de
la pandémie assez fortement donc c'est
effectivement un défaut qui a conduit
aux difficultés que reconnaissons sur la
qualité de l'emploi aujourd'hui il y a
besoin de travailler sur la
redistribution des richesses il faut
revaloriser sa retombe sur la question
du pouvoir d'achat la reconnaissance qui
est le salaire des emplois si on
augmente les salaires on augmente les
moyens de financer la retraite
évidemment c'est moins tout ce qu'on
gagne en salaire c'est moins qui part
sur les marchés financiers dans la
spéculation mais on a bien vu que les
dividendes sont à nouveau où était à
nouveau à des niveaux records donc la
question elle est aussi posée en termes
de redistribution
nécessairement bon ça c'est patron une
surprise mais si vous êtes prêt à vous
mettre autour de la table mais que vous
n'êtes prêt à aucun compromis quelle est
l'utilité de cette concertation est-ce
que ça peut déboucher sur autre chose
qu'un rapport de force
puisqu'on parle de méthode bah le
passage en force il vient de qui est-ce
que le Président de la République a ne
serait-ce que pris la peine de prendre
son téléphone d'appeler les responsables
syndicaux quand tout du coup il nous a
dit qu'il allait proposer dans le cadre
de la campagne électorale pour la
présidente de la République de porter
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 65
ans non non
consisterait à nous dire c'est décidé
donc vous venez si vous le voulez bien
pour mettre en oeuvre la décision que
j'ai prise mais non est-ce que ça veut
dire parce que en effet c'est sa
proposition mais il a il a dit durant la
campagne qu'il pouvait y avoir une
clause de revoyure qui n'est pas fermée
à une certaine compromis sur sur la
question est-ce que vous vous lui dites
très très clairement nous ce ne sera
jamais plus que 62 ans exactement c'est
déjà beaucoup trop pour beaucoup 62 ans
un salarié sur deux quand il liquide sa
retraite aujourd'hui et c'est plutôt à
63 ans et demi en moyenne n'est plus en
emploi donc nous dire qu'on va reculer
l'âge de départ à la retraite ça ne
concernera que ceux qui ont encore la
chance il faut le dire comme ça d'avoir
un emploi au moment de faire valoir leur
droit à la retraite et ça va pénaliser
un ceux qui n'ont pas l'emploi parce
qu'il subiront une décote supplémentaire
deux ça va faire basculer ceux qui ont
des emplois pénibles dans la capacité
dans la validité parce que on le sait
aussi par exemple l'augmentation des
nombres de du nombre des jours d'arrêt
maladie et principalement porté par le
recul déjà de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 62 ans avec l'allongement de
la durée de cotisations à 43 ans faut
pas oublier qu'on a une durée de
cotisation à 43 ans aujourd'hui donc ce
que on ne financera pas en termes de
retraite de toute façon on le prendra en
charge sur le plan de la
validité de la capacité il n'y a aucun
fondement à reculer l'âge de départ à la
retraite ceci près qu'il y a une un
enjeu aussi économique et d'équilibre et
financier vous vous dites par exemple
est-ce que vous seriez prêt à reprendre
une conférence de financement telle
qu'elle avait eu lieu pour la précédente
le précédent projet de réforme des
retraites histoire au moins d'encadrer
et de factuellement de trouver un
consensus autour du financement de cette
réforme des retrans on a toujours dit
que nous sommes prêts et nous sommes
demandeurs de l'ouverture de négociation
qui permet d'améliorer les conditions de
la retraite dans le cadre des systèmes
de retraite existants là dessus nous
sommes prêts la conférence de
financement dont vous parlez elle avait
un défaut majeur c'est que le premier
ministre de l'époque c'était Édouard
Philippe nous interdisait de pouvoir
négocier sur un des paramètres qui est
celui de la cotisation exactement donc
si le seul paramètre sur lequel on nous
permet de discuter c'est le recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite ou la
baisse des pensions évidemment vous avez
compris que c'est pas de la concertation
ça est-ce qu'il y a une position une
commune de tous les syndicats Ivoiriens
est-ce que vous arrivez à vous mettre
d'accord tout syndicat confondus sur la
manière dont vous allez aborder ces
concertations sur la réforme
ce qu'il y a de sûr aujourd'hui c'est
que
l'ensemble des syndicats ont clairement
indiqué et de manière assez nette et
forte qu'ils y étaient opposés auricules
de l'âge de départ à la retraite Laurent
Berger dit qu'il serait vend debout
François hollyle pour la CGC dit que il
combattra le recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite
Philippe Martinez pour la CGT a dit à
peu près la même chose mais est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord sur les modalités
d'action est-ce qu'il y aura une action
commune la difficulté elle est qu'on est
encore dans cette période intermédiaire
avec une échéance électorale importante
qui va déterminer ce que sera le
gouvernement la politique pourra mettre
en oeuvre le gouvernement demain donc il
y a une interrogation un point
d'interrogation aujourd'hui donc on va
continuer on échange régulièrement
j'avais essayé de faire en sorte qu'on
ait la possibilité de dire ce que nous
disons les uns et les autres en ce
moment de manière commune plus simple
assez rapidement avec une lettre on n'a
pas voilà on n'a pas réussi à finaliser
cela
bon parce que je pense que
principalement il y a cette
interrogation en perspective de
l'élection législative moi je pense
qu'on aurait pu SDT après les
législatives pour assigner une lettre
commune avec vous c'est ça que vous dit
Laurent Berger
si vous a donné un motif Laurent Berger
vous a donné l'explication est-ce que je
vous dis on est dans cette période où
voilà est-ce que c'est le bon moment pas
le bon moment de quelle manière voilà et
qu'est-ce que sera finalement la
politique que le gouvernement annoncera
et quel gouvernement quelle politique le
moment venu donc voilà c'est c'est ça
qui freine un peu les choses maintenant
les déclarations des uns des autres sont
claires donc moi je suis confiant dans
le fait que le moment venu en soit en
capacité de faire front uni pour que on
comprenne bien qu'il y a pas de passage
avec les syndicats sur le recul de l'âge
de départ ou dans la rue dans un premier
temps moi si on peut éviter d'aller dans
la rue moi c'est pas le syndicat il
manifeste pas pour manifester il appelle
pas
simplement de quand on a pas d'autre
solution je reprends une de vos
déclarations qui est ou si on nous
entend pas on se bagarre pour empêcher
le recul de l'âge de la retraite ce que
vous nous dites aujourd'hui c'est que
toute façon le
hors de question d'un recul de l'âge de
la retraite et qu'à priori on est quand
même parti pour est-ce que ça veut dire
que l'État social sera forcément chaud
j'ai un congrès qui se tient dans 10
jours maintenant à peine qui va réunir
de l'ordre de 3000 délégués de des
syndicats et faux de tous les secteurs
d'activité évidemment ce sujet sera dans
les débats sur les trois quatre jours de
débats de ce congrès et je pense que on
expliquera très clairement un qu'on est
opposé à toute forme de recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite que on tient à
ce que ce soit entendu et que si ça
n'était pas et bien nous serons en
responsabilité de prendre les décisions
qui nous paraîtront nécessaires pour que
on fasse en sorte de se faire entendre
l'action syndicale elle est liée à un
droit constitutionnel celui de
manifester dans un premier temps celui
d'en appeler à la grève des salariés si
nous ne sommes pas entendus ça fait
partie des droits fondamentaux en
matière d'action syndicale ça n'est pas
un objectif en soi encore une fois notre
objectif c'est d'être entendu je parlais
de méthode contiennent compte de nos
arguments moi je suis prêt je l'ai dit à
débattre publiquement à une heure de
grande écoute s'il le faut même avec le
président de la République sur le sujet
s'il veut pour que on mette sur la place
publique quels sont les arguments des
uns et des autres quand je dis que nous
sommes contre le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite ça n'est pas
simplement un slogan ça n'est pas parce
que les syndicats sont contre c'est
parce que nous avons des arguments à
faire valoir dernier mot lati est-ce
qu'un référendum ce serait une bonne
chose un référendum parce que d'abord on
sait très bien que très souvent on ne
répond pas véritablement à la question
posée par le référendum on l'a connu en
69 par exemple avec le général de Gaulle
de
le référendum par définition on convoque
des citoyens sur un sujet qui ne les
préoccupent pas de la même manière ou
qu'il n'est concernent pas la même
manière ou qui ne concerne pas du tout
si vous parlez de du recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite par exemple tous
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui retraités sont
concernés
et ils ne sont pas directement impactés
par le recul même si il faut avoir en
tête que ce que on est dans un système
de solidarité intergénérationnelle et
les cotisations des actifs font les
pensions des retraités donc tout est lié
donc tout et moi si il y avait ce type
de référendum j'appellerai bien sûr les
salariés retraités à voter contre le
recul de l'âge de départ
je ne suis pas du tout favorable pas de
référendum mais est-ce que vous
participeriez à une grande conférence
des progrès sociaux je crois qu'il y
avait été annoncé par Emmanuel Macron à
allaiter ça vous dites vous serez vous
serez présent alors peut-être pas aussi
personnellement je ne sais pas ce que ce
sera si ça aura lieu ou pas de ce que
j'ai compris à ce moment là c'est qu'on
était en train de nous expliquer que on
allait avec le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite dégager des ressources
pour financer d'autres dispositifs
sociaux dont l'autonomie de la prise en
charge de la dépendance moi je ne suis
pas d'accord pour que ce soit cette
approche il est pas question que on
essaye de nous faire passer la pilule du
recul là je départ à la retraite au
prétexte de tel ou telle autre
dispositif il faut séparer les sujets et
si je pousse un peu le trait cela
reviendrait à nous dire vous allez
travailler travailler mais vous
inquiétez pas avec les économies qu'on
va réaliser on a pris en charge vous en
pourrez plus on vous serez bien pris en
charge dans une belle maison de retraite
ben non c'est pas l'avenir que on
souhaite un vrai droit à la retraite
nous vous le disiez on est en pleine
campagne des législatives est-ce que
vous vous souhaitez une cohabitation à
l'issue de ces législatives à moi je
suis pas dans le champ du politique je
suis sur le terrain syndical ce que je
dis c'est que qui que ce sera et on l'a
expérimenté dans le passé à maintes et
maintes reprises y compris quand parfois
ceux qui sont gouvernement veulent faire
le bien des salariés parfois même
sincèrement il est toujours
indispensable que le syndic soit là
c'est une des raisons qui fait qu'on va
mettre l'accent d'ailleurs dans notre
congrès Force Ouvrière sur la nécessité
de convaincre toutes celles et tous ceux
qui sont éloignés du syndicat pour des
raisons diverses de la nécessité de
prendre part à l'action du syndicat deux
mains qui que ce sera qui sera aux
manettes nous aurons besoin d'être là
pour veiller à faire valoir les droits
des salariés je vous donnerez pas de
consigne de votre nous ne donnons jamais
de consignes de vote comme à la
présidentielle comme à la présidentielle
comme nous n'avons jamais donné de
consignes de vote FO est fondée sur
l'indépendance du syndicat chacun est
libre de ses convictions politiques
philosophiques de croire ou de ne pas
croire en lui demande de ne pas
intervenir dans le syndicat sur cette
base là et évidemment en retour on ne va
pas nous nous ériger en directeur de
conscience chacun est libre on éclaire
sur ce que sont opposition fondamentale
sur les droits fondamentaux sur les
questions économiques je n'hésite pas à
dire que nous sommes contre le recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite bien que
c'était porté pendant la campagne telle
est-elle candidat pour que tout un
chacun soit prévenu tout un chacun
ensuite fait son choix en tant que
citoyen mais le syndicat lui il sera
encore là demain sur les salaires sur
les retraites sur la sécu sur le service
public l'hôpital etc alors le syndicat
oui mais pas vous justement on va parler
de votre congrès oui parce que votre
congrès s'ouvre dans 10 jours le 30 30
mai et que on parle de votre succession
puisque vous avez décidé de ne pas
rebriger votre votre poste à la tête de
la de la Confédération qu'est-ce que
vous tirez comme bilan fondamental après
3 ans et demi de la tête
je vais pas le tirer moi-même c'est les
congressistes qui vont en débattre je
vais faire mon rapport d'activité
expliquer dans quel environnement on
s'est trouvé comment on a réagi et agi
j'ai plutôt confiance mais voilà c'est
comme ça que ça se passe par contre je
vais m'appuyer sur deux de vos collègues
l'une nous a
[Musique]
a mis un autre compte ce qu'elle a
qualifié de victoire à la fois sociale
et intellectuelle sur le système
universel de retraite par point parce
que sur ce dossier là je pense que on a
fait la démonstration que les positions
de Force Ouvrière étaient appuyées sur
un argumentaire précis sur la
connaissance précise de ce que sont les
systèmes de retraite de l'environnement
économique des questions démographiques
et nous avons réussi à convaincre du
bien-fondé de nous opposer à ce système
universel de retraite par poids je
prends cet exemple là mais ça a été vrai
sur d'autres dossiers bien d'autres
dossiers et victoire intellectuelle donc
et victoire sociale parce que on a
parallèlement parce qu'on n'a pas eu
d'autres choix que de le faire appelé à
mobiliser on a véritablement je pense
été à l'initiative de cette mobilisation
importante qui a eu lieu lorsque le
gouvernement
nous disait que on avait remis FO au
centre du jeu social on a été à
l'initiative de deux accords importants
au niveau national interprofessionnel au
moment où ces questions étaient au
centre des préoccupations des salariés
le télétravail la santé au travail donc
voilà
est-ce que vous avez des regrets ou des
choses que vous auriez aimé faire et que
vous n'avez pas fait non parce que
si des regrets au sens où ce que je vous
disais faire en sorte d'être plus
efficace pour convaincre le plus grand
nombre de salariés de rejoindre Laurent
on n'a pas eu suffisamment le temps de
travailler là-dessus pourquoi parce que
il y a eu ce conflit sur les retraites
parce que le mouvement des gilets jaunes
a révélé justement la nécessité de
convaincre celles et ceux qui ne sont
pas
partis prenantes de l'action des
syndicats il y a eu la pandémie aussi
qui nous a quand même
ultra mobilisé et la réforme de
l'assurance chômage également donc voilà
c'est cet aspect des choses et ça ça
fait partie des dossiers importants
qu'on a mis en avant à débattre dans ce
congrès on peut remettre en oeuvre
je veux pas un peu plombier mais ce
quinquennat était aussi dur pour les
syndicats parce que les combats ont été
rude vis-à-vis de ordonnance travail
enfin j'ai pas vouloir faire réforme des
retraites tout ça a été très compliqué
finalement le poids des syndicats n'a
pas été à la mesure on a pas
l'impression que vous avez pu influer en
tout cas sur autant que vous le
souhaiteriez est-ce que vous pensez que
ce prochain quinquennat va être encore
plus dur moi je crois que on ne mesure
pas assez ce qu'est l'action au
quotidien des syndicats le système
universel de retraite par point si vous
vous souvenez c'était dans le programme
du président à élu quand il était en
campagne en 2017 il appelait celle très
fort la mère des réformes la réforme de
l'assurance chômage y était associée on
a réussi quand même à la faire
déporté un temps certain malheureusement
et là effectivement c'est Madame borne
qui était à aux manettes en tant que
ministre du Travail elle a fini par nous
l'imposer sur la crise sanitaire on
l'oublie par exemple vous savez on a
beaucoup euh évoqué la mobilisation
massive de l'activité partielle ce qu'on
appelait autrefois le chômage partiel
plus personne n'a en tête que le chômage
partiel le possibilité d'être indemnisé
en chômage partiel c'est le produit
d'une négociation au sein de l'assurance
chômage en 1968 ou un accord en 1968 ou
669 j'ai pu en tête la date exacte et ça
l'assurance chômage plus personne n'a en
tête que c'est le produit de l'action
des syndicats et de FO en particulier
les retraites complémentaires elles sont
en pleine forme aujourd'hui malgré la
crise sanitaire le recapitalise des
réserves et elle permet de verser à 13
millions de pensionnés une retraite
complémentaire c'est le produit de la
négociation menée par les syndicats le
SMIC qui augmente ces trois dernières
c'est le résultat de l'action des
syndicats donc voilà on l'oublie trop on
sent que vous êtes passionné jusqu'au
bout il verriez merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été avec nous à quelques jours
de passer la main à la tête de Force
Ouvrière merci merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation l'une de la
Voix du Nord Julien une majorité se
dessine pour Emmanuel Macron un sondage
Harris Interactive pour votre journal
merci Julien merci
[Musique]